[Música]
[Aplausos]
qué es la pedagogía sistémica con el
enfoque de bélgica para que no sirve
que podemos mirar desde esta pedagogía
que ahora en este tiempo de kobe nos
pueda impulsar a seguir aprendiendo
aprender y enseñar es preferirán asunto
de la pedagogía esférica
y solo un corazón agradecido
y sólo un corazón agradecido enseño
y aquí tenemos que estar agradecidos
cuál es el efecto de la gratitud
a donde podemos mirar
con más intención para agradecer
punto importante uno de los pilares más
importantes dentro de la pedagogía
sistémica son nuestros padres
y sobre esto quiero hablar sobre este
pilar que es uno de los que sostienen
este enfoque este enfoque que se traduce
después en un modelo
y que necesitamos mirar
muchos años los padres estuvieron
excluidos del aula
nosotros como maestros yo tengo muchos
años en la docencia muchísimos años y lo
que yo enseñaba hace algunos años era
química
y cuando yo llega al aula tenía toda la
intención de que mis alumnos aprendieran
química
cuando no querían aprenderla
pero mi misión como maestra en ese
momento era que los chicos pudiesen
aprender química para ir el segundo paso
entonces yo me da como venderles la
materia esta materia que no quieren
comprar
entonces descubrí que el aprendizaje
tiene que tener dirección
sentido significado y que me guste
y eso es importante entonces empezar
desde el marketing en el aula como podía
y poder enseñar a los chicos para que
ellos aprendiese
pero no
mucho tiempo no lo pude lograr
hay algo había una barrera y que no me
permitía aceptar a los chicos
y este enfoque de la pedagogía sistémica
cuando nosotros lo vamos descubriendo
nos da esta respuesta
sólo un corazón de agradecido puede
aprender y a veces nuestros alumnos no
estén agradecidos con el hecho de estar
en escuela
y ustedes se preguntarán por qué porque
no era dicen que estar en la escuela
pues porque es muchísimo el esfuerzo el
sacrificio que hacen los padres y ellos
no lo pueden llamar
entonces este derecho a aprender
de nuestras generaciones más jóvenes
tenemos que impulsarlo
con este darle un sentido a lo que están
aprendiendo ellos y esta es la pedagogía
sistémica cuando el chico fisio lo hago
por ti papá luego para ti papá todo por
la familia incluso los adultos que
estamos estudiando decimos lo hacemos
para las siguientes generaciones y nos
sentimos
y perfil y que nos dice lo más
importante es mirar a los padres
entonces pero que sistémica el pilar es
la inclusión de los padres en el proceso
de cómo aprenden los chicos y como
enseña y cuando los padres están dando
oportunidades de el alma de los padres
para que los chicos aprendan y voy a dar
un ejemplo hace unos años
yo voy a cambiar los nombres así no
sabes tenía un alumno que se llama diego
y de repente diego venía a la escuela y
quería salirse por cualquier puerta no
se queda
la madre vino y dijo bueno tiene
trastorno por déficit de atención con
hiperactividad
y los maestros y entenderlo
y en mi experiencia en todos los países
que están en muchos países
aplicando esta pedagogía
este trastorno por déficit de atención
con hiperactividad no podemos resolver
los maestros hacemos todo lo que podemos
pero qué se trata esto yo descubrí algo
con esta dinámica
pues el viejo llegaba a la escuela muy
contento y a la segunda hora quería
salirse pero de inmediato brincarse la
barda y hacer toda serie de estrategias
para poder salir de la escuela
entonces bueno me encuentro a la mamá un
día en el jardín de aquí de la escuela y
me dice a diego lo han dado de baja
porque reprobó suspendió todas las
materias
y entonces yo le pregunté a la mamá
fueron pero y que hace que si tu hijo en
casa y fíjese algo súper interesante me
dice diego en casa se queda al lado de
la cocina por la computadora y no se
mueve en toda la tarde
izquierda aquí tiene trastorno por
déficit de atención con hiperactividad y
ella está tranquilito y
y le dije y que hace allí toda la tarde
no sabe jugar con sus amigos
y me dice no
y entonces le dije cierran los ojos
imagínate a tu hijo
aquí está cuidando
a ella se le salen las lágrimas y dice a
mí
y le dije por qué porque he tenido dos
intentos de suicidio
claro
me pregunto este trastorno por déficit
de atención con hiperactividad
me pregunto a dónde viene la atención
dijo
pues en su casa con su mona y se imagina
que cuando salía de escuela
llega a casa y su mamá está vuelta
no sé si no podía estar en la escuela
y entonces cada vez que me hablan de
trastorno por déficit de atención me
recuerdo dónde está la atención del niño
que no voy a aprender en la escuela y
entonces en pedagogía sistémica porque
el aprendizaje tiene que ver con un
sistema el sistema de la familia el
sistema de la escuela envuelto en el
sistema social en el que nosotros
estamos esto es una pedagogía sistémica
con el enfoque de bergen que es mirar
cómo interactúan estos sistemas
entonces
i
y que piensa diego cada vez que llega a
la escuela
y me contestó de una manera que nunca
voy a olvidar
y se piensa lo mismo techo
porque mi papá se suicidó
así es esto es una historia que se está
repitiendo
y esto descubre ver hellinger hay unas
dinámicas que se repiten
y entonces
les pregunté que te hubiera gustado
decirle a mi papá
un experto
y dice me hubiera gustado decirle porque
no te quedaste a cuidarlos
y le dirigió tiene tiene muchísimo miedo
de que tú no te tienes para cuidarlos a
él ya sus hermanitos
entonces cuál es la frase le dije que
podría regresar y decirle bien
y dijo
que yo me quedo y los cuido
yo me comprometo a quedarme aquí
bueno esa conversación que duró
escasamente 10 minutos
a mí me transformó
porque es donde está el amor de nuestros
alumnos dónde está el amor de los niños
siempre está en casa
siempre
bueno yo salió de la escuela porque no
podía quedarse porque ya no podía seguir
en el año escolar porque había reprobado
todas las materias
pero al año siguiente regreso
y fue
un alumno extraordinario
después estuvo trabajando con nosotros y
diego para mí era el sol que me decía
que se pueden solucionar las cosas por
muy
graves quisiera
diego es un profesionista súper exitoso
y no pudo hacer este giro y entonces los
chicos pueden aprender
porque trastorno por déficit de atención
y me quedé con ese gran amor que tienen
los niños por su familia y mi atención
está en casa principalmente la escuela
solo ese escaparate donde se muestran
todos estos fenómenos todas estas
dinámicas
y con esta pedagogía los maestros
podemos comprender estas dinámicas y
generar un campo de comprensión donde
los contenidos curriculares puedan fluir
y hemos visto casos extraordinarios con
intervenciones sistémicas
que son como
muy finas
chinas y profundas
entonces el pilar uno de los pilares más
importantes de la pedagogía sistémica
son los malos la inclusión de la
historia de los padres en el aula
los padres son exitosos hacen muchos
proyectos su vida
está ordenada los hijos van a mostrar
ese hombre si los padres tienen
problemas existenciales tan fuertes pues
los hijos vana
mostrar
este gran dolor para que se le suelo
y así
los padres de nuestros alumnos están
siempre incluidos en el aula porque
principalmente la escuela firme a la
familia ya los padres sirve ha sido la
más importante de la sociedad y en la
familia que son los vargas
y servimos a través de la educación de
sus hijos nuestros alumnos
este es un pilar importantísimo de la
pedagogía sistémica
nosotros yo y lo particular
trabajado para un modelo pedagógico
sistémico con el enfoque de berger
inglés
qué es
en profundidad maravilloso porque
solamente es mirar la historia de la
familia de cada uno de nosotros para
poder comprenderla y darle las gracias
es muy difícil dar las gracias a un
destino
aquí
nos ha dolido mucho como en este caso la
madre se ha suicidado el padre
y la madre ha tenido dos intentos
pero
hay solución
hay solución y ahora con el comino y con
este retiro obligatorio
hemos visto cómo surgen dinámicas que
tienen que ser resueltas
dinámicas familiares históricas la
historia del padre y la historia de la
madre la historia del matrimonio la
historia de la separación y con esta
tenemos que trabajar en la escuela
y así
de esta manera amorosa y comprensiva
podemos hablar que la inclusión de los
padres de familia en el trabajo
pedagógico es totalmente irrevocable
la historia de la familia está sentada o
en el aula o ahora está sentada frente a
la computadora y ocurre detrás del
comunicador
entonces estas dinámicas se han visto
evidentes ahora a través de esta escuela
virtual este ha sido el gran aprendizaje
y darle las gracias al móvil yo le llamo
el maestro kovic porque son las 20 un
corazón agradecido
grindr
solamente un corazón que agradece esta
situación que nos está envolviendo
sólo este corazón agradecido aprende las
lecciones que nos da que nos está dando
este maestro pobre
y entonces los que somos maestros
podemos enseñar porque estamos
agradecidos
solo un corazón agradecido aprende sólo
un corazón agradecido
[Aplausos]